yes this is not a review of BioShock
Infinite I'm currently playing that
right now but I thought it would make
sense before I review BioShock Infinite
to review the original BioShock I mean
y'all agree that makes sense right
Bioshock so Bioshock was a first-person
shooter that came out in 2008 and pretty
much everyone loved it it was back when
game developers weren't afraid to make
survival horror type games because they
were cool than it wasn't all about the
action genre in Bioshock you're a guy
who was in a plane crash you survived
you're in the middle of the ocean and
you find this pod that takes you down to
this underwater utopia called rapture
from there game gets crazy and then
crazier rapture was created to be free
of God free of country it's its own
thing
free of rules and rapture mankind is
free to become all he can be and now we
have a survival horror game now in
Bioshock being a first-person shooter
it's all about the intro how's it going
to start out it has a pretty rough start
in my opinion because you're like I have
a wrench and two bullets for my pistol
suite of being attacked by four guys two
of them are shooting a me two of them
are melee yeah rough start and after
that you're like I need to conserve my
ammo because I'm clearly not going to
have a lot of it and that's the way it
is for about 1/3 to halfway through the
game after that feel free to waste
anything with any amount of ammo you
have if you run out of ammo rest assured
you have enough money to buy ammo you
run out of money don't worry you'll get
it back pretty quickly yeah there's more
money in ammo in this game than you know
what to do with by the end you feel like
you're wasteful like I am just throwing
away not getting it screw those
sandwiches screw those med packs screw
those bullets screw that money America
but in this game dealing with unlocking
biology you do get abilities you know
you can shoot fire from your hands
lightning from your hands still
explained with science of course but oh
yeah you have magic in the end it
doesn't matter what magic you get or
what weapons you get because you find
out the most effective weapon is to take
any inanimate object with the force hold
it in front of you and throw it at a
guy's head when he attacks you instant
death for the most part as for the
creepy factor this game certainly has it
I love the tone of Bioshock the best and
only way to play Bioshock is in the dark
lights off at night and sound up has a
really ominous tone you hear people
talking to themselves these chicks are
like I'll be pretty healthy pretty
you're like mmm
well you're in rapture so I'm going to
shoot you in the face before you do
anything to me could've been a nice
chick maybe she just want to be pretty
but now she's
so we'll never know I remember this one
scene this light came on behind me and I
looked up and I was oh that shadow
effects cool I can see my that's not my
shadow and you turn around this dude's
right in your face and you're like
yeah I haven't really felt like that
since like the original Resident Evil
for this one dude was on the ceiling yet
hooks for hands I just blew him away and
he's just hanging there and the music
kicks on it's all like how much is that
doggy in the window I was just like I'm
gonna go now yeah I don't know why it
was just unsettling the situation was
done there was nothing else attacking me
I didn't want to stay in the room I mean
there are rooms in this game I'm not
even gonna ruin free because it'll ruin
the effect I'm like Oh in this room
you'll be like oh thanks dick you just
told me so creeped out factor in
Bioshock is a check and other thing you
have to deal with are the big daddies in
Bioshock you got to get this chemical
from these little girls it's called Adam
but before you do that you got to take
on their guardians the big daddies these
dudes are enormous and they're pretty
docile if you don't mess with them they
don't care about you but eventually you
do have to engage them and they kick the
out of you at first by the end of
the game you're like I'm more powerful
than you grenade launchers grenade
launchers crossbow because I'm all
Norman Reedus from walking dead and
before that though they are a menace
they dispatch you with extreme prejudice
it's not like some big solomon grundy is
like oh they're fast and they hit hard
and you just don't want to deal with
them you're like alright let's get
this over with
in Bioshock you equip these stat buffs
in certain categories you know they buff
yeah it's pretty commonplace for first
person RPGs at this point when Bioshock
came out it absolutely wasn't everyone's
like what is this just like a
first-person shooter with RPG elements
like what is this this is not your
common first-person shooter no it is not
and usually I'd say oh that's the
gimmick but it still holds up today
another thing I like in Bioshock you can
hack electronic devices how you hack
comes kind of a minigame you unlock all
these little pieces and you got to
ultimately connect point a with point B
before the water gets to the end it's a
water pipe type game but I love that
game it's one of those minigames that
such a puzzle on your mind that when
you're going to bed that's all you see
in your head Bioshock invade your mind
with the pipe puzzle game now when
you're done with Bioshock you may think
to yourself it's good but it's a little
overhyped didn't you really start
thinking about the message that Bioshock
has about humanity and in your mind it
becomes more than just a first-person
shooter or some art
elements to it it's more than just
survival Horrors more than just on
experiment went bad in this underwater
city the message I get from the hope
Bioshock franchise is ultimately it's a
delve into humanity what makes humans
human and if they're free to do whatever
they want free of law what would they do
what would they become but they become
something that's not human anymore and
if they do that is that actually what
humanity is human nature is not civil if
you don't have rules and laws in place
humanity goes to a very dark place it
all really it's in your head you know
you start thinking about that
you're like man a game did that a game
so Bioshock was creepy as it was a
lot of fun it had a good story to it it
was really intense and it had a good
message of humanity I don't know if it
was a good message it was a relevant
enough message that makes you go hmm
whether I like that or not I'm now
thinking about it and it's intriguing
the out of me Bioshock certainly is
awesome tacular
Bioshock is the show lost and the game
Resident Evil had a kid that sums it up
right there yeah for some Bioshock have
you played it why did you think about it
do you think it still holds up today
although it's a simple like five years
later at this point but five years is a
lifetime in terms of game life whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more would you kindly